sent him this picture
yeah and it's fairly obvious she's got
two bruises there star hobson's aunt
alicia is speaking for the first time
about events leading to her niece's
murder how she warned social services
and the police but no one listened the
day that it happened i knew that it
wasn't an accident i knew that it was
you know i knew that
yeah i was right and they should have
listened
sixteen-month-old star hobson was
murdered by savannah brockhill while the
child's mother frankie smith was found
guilty of causing or allowing her death
starr had suffered terrible cruelty for
months before she was beaten to death in
september 2020
but seen here with alicia she was very
loved and looked out for by her extended
family
she loved music
my grandad would play the guitar and my
nan had this thing in the kitchen it was
like
a washing dryer and she'd always bang it
and make noise she loved music and
dancing for the happiest 10 weeks of her
life starr lived with her
great-grandparents
star do you with your mums but when her
mother took her back things started to
change
the family had heard that smith's new
girlfriend brock hill who was an amateur
boxer had been slammed choking the
little girl
so they referred them to social services
that is around the time that me and my
nan and granddad got banned from seeing
star
because we spoke to social services so
we so
you were banned by by frankie and
savannah yeah
frankie's my sister but
no matter what i have when you get a gut
feeling you have to follow your gut
feeling
star had a little bruise on a cheek a
little tiny
and it easily could have been from just
a fall that a bruise like that it was a
tiny tiny little
um bruise but i just i don't know i just
knew something went right
social services believed smith and brock
hill's assertions that the family was
being malicious
i'm coming
i'm coming for you
so star who loved playing with her aunt
lost contact with the only people trying
to protect her it just hurt me to think
somebody he's he's calling me malicious
for trying to protect
my niece
it just felt like well if they don't
believe me who who is who is going to
believe me
a month later alicia contacted the
police and emailed them these
photographs she'd been sent by a younger
sister who comments that you can see the
bruises she also sent a screenshot of a
snapchat conversation with her sister
who messaged her saying i've just seen
frankie slap her across the face oh my
god
i'm fuming
tell nana
okay
something bad's gonna happen why did she
hit her because she was playing with her
shoe slapped for playing with a shoe the
row that led to her death started
because star was playing with a concert
ticket at this period of time i was just
angry every day because no one were
listening to me and i just felt like
all all i could have done is
taken her and ran off of her the police
officer never got back to me how did you
feel the police not getting back to you
angry
i just felt
yeah just angry
police did take staff for a medical
check but the doctor supported the
mother's claim that injuries could have
been caused by falling on a coffee table
in july social services closed the case
the family made another referral in
august the last time alicia would see
star and how was she when you saw her
star yeah in august
just not star
she um
she just had like
her eyes which she just looked tired or
eyebags she would just
she wanted us chunky
she just looked
sad
in september 2020 starr died at her
mother's flat here in keithley after
being beaten and suffering catastrophic
abdominal injuries both smith and brock
hill claimed to be out of the room when
it happened that they'd heard a bang
implying she'd had a fall the excuse
they'd used before to explain star's
bruising
i said to my mum i said i know that's a
lie
and then a few days later she got
arrested
um
and that from that day i just decided i
can't speak to her
so
i must be tough for you though because
it's your sister yeah she was like my
best friend as well
so it's like losing two people in one
a postmortem found star alicia hobson
had over 30 previous injuries including
fractures in her ribs legs and skull in
the wake of this bradford council
apologized and was stripped of
responsibility for running children's
social care last week it welcomed a
review into the toddler's death which
will become part of a wider national
review i think they need to be more on
on the on the ball
and
time is crucial so
like frankie was just texting her social
worker saying
like we've got a sickness bug can we
rearrange and she was just replying no
worries whereas they should have been
like well no you cannot you can't
rearrange you know
this needs to be
you know followed up i need to see today
they just fought all of frankie's family
was being malicious and they'd already
decided that they'd taken their side
that's what it felt like it felt like
the social services were against us
but compare star's affection for alicia
to how she behaves in the care of her
killer savannah brockhill who's spoiled
being spoiled
i actually didn't get to see that video
until um after star had passed away
because um savannah and frankie had
blocked me
pretty girl you were spoiled pretty girl
you can just tell the difference you can
see in her eyes she just looked scared
like a teddy bear
once
two statically everywhere
serious girl
what are your thoughts now first of all
about savannah
i
i don't even have words i just
in our family we
don't even say her name we call her the
monster we can't it's just how someone
can
do that it's not
she took star and she's took frankie she
just destroyed the whole family and how
do you feel about your sister now
each day some days i wake up and uh
i miss her but then i just think it's
not the same person who's
when i was at trial that was hard
but when
i looked i was thinking that's not who i
miss she's not that person anymore it
will never be the same again i mean
i will love her in private but i just i
can't ever speak to her again i just
can't do it i just feel angry because i
think if that was me and that was my
child i would have got away i would have
got out of that situation no matter what
so i'm i can't forgive that
alicia says the family has been ripped
apart and that someone who brought such
joy
is now a huge void
in all their lives
jason farrell sky news
and we did ask west yorkshire police for
their response to jason's report and
they told us we are unable to comment as
there is an ongoing iopc investigation